All right, everybody, this is this is really it.
We're down to the last days of this 20-20
presidential and Senate and House election and
everything that we have been predicting about the
way this election is going to go down is coming
true. The voter suppression, the use of the courts
and lawsuits by Donald Trump to stop the counting
of votes. He's saying he's going to do it.
The encouraging of violence, which I am going
to get to shortly. And now a leak to Axios that
Donald Trump's plan, if it is even remotely
plausible that he might win on election night,
he is planning to declare victory. This is not a
rehearsal. These are the last 36 hours and they
are doing it. And democracy is at stake here.
It is not time to be hyperbolic, which is why
I am telling it to you like it is. Democracy is at
stake here. And this is, of course, exactly as we
have been predicting for months, even though
we never have final results on Election Day.
Typically, there is enough information
on Election Day to make a call about the
winner. Donald Trump's plan, if it's close, if
it's tight, will be to declare that he has won,
which will weaponize his supporters in the
event the numbers start turning against him
as the mail in ballots are all counted.
And he will put pressure on the courts
to have to take it from him by saying, on election
night, I won, I'm the winner. This is from an
Axios report which reports that, quote, President
Trump has told confidants he will declare victory
on Tuesday night if it looks like he's ahead,
according to three sources familiar with his
private comments. Trump will declare victory even
if the Electoral Electoral College outcome will
still depend on uncounted votes in key states like
Pennsylvania. Trump has a plan which he has talked
about with aides to get up in front of a podium
somewhere. It looked like it was going to be
at one of his hotels. Now it looks like it will
be at the White House itself and declare that
he has won. Now, this is not a no matter what
scenario. If Trump gets totally blown out early,
he's not going to do this. In fact, he'll do
the opposite, which is if Biden looks like he's
way ahead. Trump will say the numbers don't
look right and we have to wait until all the
votes come in. But in any scenario other than
a Biden blowout in which he leads or wins some
combination of Ohio, Florida, North Carolina,
Texas, Iowa, Arizona, Georgia, Pennsylvania,
he will be saying, I won. We have been reelected.
Now, Trump's team is preparing to make this claim
more specific by alleging that mail in ballots
counted after November 3rd shouldn't be allowed,
that those ballots would be evidence of election
fraud. How can people vote after November 3rd?
It's not true, but they're going to say
it. And prognosticators say that it is
very plausible that on election night, Trump might
be slightly ahead in, for example, Pennsylvania.
There are many scenarios in which Trump needs
Pennsylvania to win. The entire election could
hinge on Pennsylvania. And Pennsylvania is seeing
five plus day delays for normal mail to be sent
back and forth. Pennsylvania is the the site
of a lot of a preemptive legal wrangling. So
you could have a situation where Trump claiming
victory in Pennsylvania implies that he got 270
electoral vote votes, but he could end up losing
Pennsylvania. If and when all of the properly
legally cast ballots are counted, the Axios
report goes on to say that Donald Trump's team
is baselessly planning to claim that Democrats
have stolen the election. If the results flip
from Trump to Biden as mail in ballots are counted
and Accio says that this is the first time Trump
has actually explicitly discussed these intentions
for Tuesday night. He's been alluding to it for
a while, but now he's actually saying it now. I
must remind everybody. So we're on the same page.
Listen very carefully here. We have never
had full final results on Election Day.
No state ever reports final certified results
on election night. No state is expected to. The
news organizations will start to make projections
based on ballots, outstanding state demographics,
exit polls and more to make calls about who likely
has won. Typically, they can do this relatively
accurately because we know there aren't that
many outstanding ballots because most people are
voting in person. You can get to a point where,
you know, North Carolina, Biden's up 55 45 in a
normal election, 55 45 with 20 percent to go. And
in order to take back that lead, Trump would need
80 percent of the remaining 20 percent of that not
going to happen. You make a call, North Carolina
goes for Biden. This is going to be different
because there are so many people voting by mail
reports of mail delays, et cetera, et cetera. But
the results are never final. On election night,
it's actually even crazier. Trump is saying
we need all of the results on November 3rd
when the polls close in Hawaii, it will already be
November 4th on the East Coast. What Trump wants
is impossible unless you want to make
some metaphysical argument about time
moving backwards or something like that. So the
difference this year is not the timing of the
final results. The difference is when news
organizations will have enough information
to make accurate projections. He's going to try to
steal it. He's going to declare victory on Tuesday
in every scenario other than a massive blowout by
Joe Biden. So we must all be ready for that. And
we must be ready for the opposite scenario
where if Trump is down hugely at midnight,
he may reverse course and say there's no way these
numbers are right based on our internal polling.
We are not conceding anything, which
is, of course, just a formality,
even if Biden has a blowout. Trump will say,
well, now we have to wait. But hopefully at that
point it will be too late. The strategy is cheat
lawyers discounting ballots, claiming victory.
Biden's lawyers had better be ready for some
long nights because democracy is depending on it.
The future of our public health and economy
also depends on it. Let's talk about that.